good morning John a couple of weeks ago
I introduced you and the nerdfighters to
a friend of mine and and people seemed
to like him despite the fact that I'm
not a real big fan but since you liked
him I decided to invite him back so I
could ask them a couple of questions
John nerdfighters everyone please
welcome back to the show
daemon four-year-old a human brain
weighs three pounds that's a very
interesting fact daemon four-year-old
how did you learn that three pounds well
anyway I'm not sure that I want to keep
calling you daemon four-year-old cuz
it's a little bit creepy so maybe you
could just introduce yourself to us in
tumescence into in gym essence I don't
know what that means
I'm gonna check my phone I'm gonna I'm
gonna hook that one up just hold on just
second demon four-year-old in tumescence
a swelling up with blood or other fluids
that is a very big word for a
four-year-old um is that what you want
us to call you okay in tumescence is it
it seems like a bit of a long maybe we
can short that we can call you to me to
me everybody losers
okay this interview is getting out of my
control must bring it back together must
control the interview to me what is your
favorite food penguins know what that
might be your favorite animal what is
your favorite food penguins I'm hoping
at least that you're misunderstanding
the question here they taste of God fish
mixed with the heart of an or rock and
you're not misunderstanding the question
okay ah what else do you like I like
Glenn Beck okay and that is officially
where the interview ends but that that's
just too much for me okay and then the
demon four-year-old has cursed me with a
thunderstorm so the lighting changed but
anyway John you and I we were supposed
to get punished I have not done my
makeup tutorial yet and you are likewise
significantly unpunished I think that we
both need to
even agreement here seven days from now
our punishments will be complete John
now I need to banish you because you
cannot watch this video and I've swear
it has nothing to do with the fact that
your birthday is coming up really soon
just go away okay John is gone now John
is gone now nerdfighters its John's
birthday coming up August 24th is the
day and I have got a plan to make a
video in a way that no one has made a
video ever in the history of time and in
that video there will be thousands of
nerdfighters in order participate this
independent habit of it and in order to
participate in this you need to go to
nerdfighters comm and sign up for the
secret project mailing list the secret
project mailing list is used for all
kinds of secret projects that we as
nerdfighteria do together additionally
there's going to be a link to
instructional videos at the end of this
video so that you can know how to do the
thing that we are doing but it'll be
most important that you read the emails
that are coming into your inbox after
you subscribe okay everyone thank you so
much for participating in John's
birthday video there will be lots of
instructions as for how to participate
and they will be different ways of
participating and okay now I am done
demon four year old gone John gone now
Hank
gone dftba everyone
you
I'll Biggs orgasm lasts for over 30
minutes what what is that even how does
how does anyone even know that who is
the guy with the electrode measuring the
quivering of the pig genitalia hmm
[Music]